avant d'évoquer euh le fond de cette
crise agricole parlons d'ordre public
les agriculteurs ont mené beaucoup
d'actions coup de point cette semaine le
pays est vraiment bloqué et Gérald
d'agnen le ministre d'intérieur estime
euh qu'il faut laisser faire les
agriculteurs que ce sont des coups de
sang légitime je le cite est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord est-ce que c'est pas du
laxisme de la part du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est quand même
responsable de l'ordre public je ne suis
pas d'accord avec la position du
ministre de l'intérieur quand on est
ministre de l'intérieur on fait
respecter l'ordre quel que soit celui
qui manifeste rest qu'on l'aime ou qu'on
l'aime pas la question n'est pas
celle-ci ça s'appelle l'ordre public le
fonctionnement républicain de ce pays
donc on fait respecter la règles si les
règles sont respectées et que les gens
manifestent comme il est d'usage de
façon organisée déclarée et respectueuse
de tout le monde il y a évidemment aucun
problème mais à partir du moment où un
manifestant quel qu'il soit quel que
soit sa la la légitimité de sa
contestation enfin les règles de la
République pose des difficultés bah oui
il y a un moment il faut il faut arrêter
les choses il faut remettre un peu
d'ordre al ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que il y a façon et façon de
remettre de l'ordre hein on peut le
faire de façon tout à fait consensuelle
discuter aborder les sujets trouver des
points d'accord avant de passer j'allais
dire à des mesures beaucoup plus
coeritives donc ne mettons pas comme
principe que finalement parce qu'on est
gentil ou parce qu'on aime bien les uns
ou les autres on est plus souple avec
les uns ou avec les autres enfin je veux
dire c'est déjà contraire à tous les
principes de la
République